MORE BREAKING TONIGHT ON
OF THE UNION ADDRESS AND MORE
PEOPLE WATCHED THE FOX NEWS
CHANNEL.
WE WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
TRUSTING US AND WE WANT TO EARN
THAT TRUST EVERY DAY.
CONSERVATIVE PRINCIPLES AND
THEY'RE WORK.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF DEMOCRATS
LED BY NEGATIVE NANCY PELOSI
HAND WITH AN SCOWL ON THEIR FACE
AND YOU SEE THE DEMOCRATS
PLAYING PETTY PARTISAN POLITICS.
WAGES.
AFRICAN AMERICAN UNEMPLOYMENT
STANDS AT THE LOWEST RATE EVER
HAS ALSO REACHED THE LOWEST
LEVELS IN HISTORY.
>> Sean: WE'LL HAVE MORE ON THE
DEMOCRATS RIDICULOUS BEHAVIOR.
THEY DON'T HAVE SOLUTION OR
STAND FOR ANYTHING EXCEPT THEY
HATE PRESIDENT TRUMP.
DURING CHANT OF "USA" AND HIS
EXCUSE
EXCUS
EXCUSE?
HE HAD TO GET READY FOR AN
INTERVIEW AND PELOSI AND THE
DEMOCRATS ARE BEING CALLED OUT
WITH SOME POWERFUL TRUTHS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I THINK NANCY PELOSI LOOKS
LIKE THAT ALL THE TIME.
I THINK SHE SHOULD SMILE A LOT
MORE OFTEN.
I THINK THE COUNTRY WOULD BE
SHE SEEMS TO EMBODY THE
BITTERNESS IN THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY.
LAST NIGHT WAS A STEP FORWARD.
HOPEFULLY THEY CAN LET GO OF
SOME OF THAT AND THEY NEED TO
DECIDE, DO THEY LOVE AMERICA
MORE THAN THEY HATE THE
PRESIDENT AND PUT THE
DIFFERENCES ASIDE AND COME
TOGETHER AND DO WHAT'S RIGHT FOR
FIX THE COUNTRY AND HELP THE
FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN.
WILL THE DEMOCRATS EVER PUT THAT
BEFORE THE HATRED OF THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY SUPPORTED EIGHT YEARS OF
THE LOWEST LABOR PARTICIPATION
IN 51 YEARS AND OBAMA
ACCUMULATED MORE DEBT THAN EVERY
THE COURSE OF HIS PRESIDENCY IN
ANY ONE GIVEN YEAR.
THE MEDIA ARE IN FULL HYSTERIA
MODE.
THEY'RE BIAS IS SO TRANSPARENT.
>> WHAT YOU SAW TONIGHT WAS
DEMOCRATS, AND WITH THE OTHER
HAND, HOLDING UP A FIST.
>> IF THE PRESIDENT MET WITH ME
AFTER THE SPEECH I WOULD SAY
THAT'S HOW NOT TO GIVE A
UNIFYING SPEECH.
>> IT'S RACIAL TENSIONS BY
BRINGING UP THE ISSUE OF KNEEL.
>> THE RHETORIC SET THINGS BACK.
>> IF THAT WAS AN ATTEMPT AT
UNITY HE'S GOT A LOT OF WORK TO
DO.
>> I GO THROUGH THE TELEPROMPTER
SPEECHES YOU CAN TELL HE'S
READING IT.
>> HE WAS SELLING SWEET TASTING
CANDY WITH POISON IN IT.
>> IT'S DEEP AND ALMOST A SAD
OBSESSION WITH BEING LIKED.
THE GREAT DICTATOR.
>> NO, BUT THEY'RE NOT SUPPOSED
TO SIT ON THEIR HANDS.
ON FULL-ON CONSPIRACY MODE ABOUT
THE COLOR OF THE FIRST LADY'S
>> IS THERE ANYTHING YOU WANT TO
TELL US ABOUT HER OUTFIT.
>> SHE'S WEARING A CREAM-COLORED
SUIT I FIND INTERESTING.
LAST YEAR THE FEMALE DEMOCRATIC
SENATORS ALL WORE WHITE TO
PROTEST TRUMP'S POLICIES AGAINST
WOMEN.
FIND A LOT OF STUFF SHE DOES
THESE DAYS TO LOOK AT TWICE
>> Sean: AND THEY CAN'T GIVE UP
THEIR OBSESSION WITH THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
EVEN MOMENTS BEFORE THE STATE OF
THE UNION, THIS TOO A DISGRACE.
WATCH.
>> THIS IS A PRESIDENT UNDER
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION FOR
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE WITH
REGARD TO THE RUSSIA
INVESTIGATION.
A LOT GOING ON IN THE BACKDROP.
>> THERE'S A MISSING MAJOR
FIGURE IN THE HALL WE AUTH --
OUGHT NOT TO FORGET ABOUT AND
THAT'S THE SPECIAL PROSECUTOR AT
THE UNITED STATES WHO IS
PROBABLY AT THIS HOUR MEETING
WITH HIS TEAM.
THAT'S AN EXTRAORDINARILY
IMPORTANT PART OF WHAT'S GOING
ON IN WASHINGTON, D.C.
>> Sean: IT SHOWS HOW OUT OF
TOUCH THE LIBERAL MAINSTREAM
DESTROY TRUMP DOES.
THEY ALREADY PRE DETERMINED
THEY'RE GOING TO HATE IT BUT
YOU, THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAD A
DIFFERENT REACTION.
LET'S LOOK AT THE CBS NEWS POLL.
75% OF PEOPLE WATCHED APPROVED
OF THE PRESIDENT'S SPEECH.
SPEECH WATCHERS HAD A POSITIVE
REACTION.
NOW, IF YOU JUST WATCHED THE
MEDIA'S HYSTERICAL COVERAGE
WOULDN'T KNOW ANY OF THIS AND
THINK EVERYONE HATED HIS SPEECH.
THIS WHY ON THIS PROGRAM WE CALL
THEM THE DESTROY TRUMP MEDIA.
AND WE HAVE MASSIVE DEVELOPMENTS
REGARDING THE RELEASE OF THE
FOUR-PAGE CLASSIFIED MEMO
EXPOSING OBAMA-ERA SURVEILLANCE
OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND
TRANSITION AND THERE'S DEBATE
DOCUMENT.
I FOR ONE, AM FOR FULL
TRANSPARENCY AND I DON'T WANT
ANYTHING REDACT.
MAYBE IF IT COMPROMISES SECURITY
IT'S ABOUT GETTING THE TRUTH OUT
AND THAT'S SCARING THE LIVING
HELL OUT OF SOME PEOPLE AT THE
FBI AND DOJ AND ROD ROSENSTEIN
AND PETER STRZOK.
FISA WARRANT TO LITERALLY SPY
TON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN MANAGER.
ROSENSTEIN IS SHAKING IN HIS
BOOTS TONIGHT.
WE'RE HEARING FROM SOURCES HE'S
ASKING IF ROSENSTEIN WAS ON HIS
TEAM.
SOME MAY WANT TO CHECK HIS PHONE
RECORDS AND E-MAILS BECAUSE
ISN'T IT A LITTLE TOO CONVENIENT
WHEN THE WALLS BEGIN TO CLOSE IN
ON HIM, ESPECIALLY AFTER McCABE
BEING FIRED ALL OF A SUDDEN
NOW SARA CARTER WHO WILL JOIN US
RELEASING THE MEMO WOULD BE
AND THERE'S GRAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
ACCURACY.
TODAY THE FBI ARE TRYING TO TAKE
SHOTS AT THE MEMO.
YESTERDAY KATHERINE HERRIDGE
SAID TWO FBI OFFICIALS COULD NOT
POINT TO ANY FACTUAL
INACCURACIES AND DEVIN NUNES
SAID THIS, HAVING STONEWALLED
CONGRESSES DEMANDS FOR
INFORMATION FOR NEARLY A YEAR,
IT'S NO SURPRISE TO SEE THE FBI
AND DOJ FILE SPURIOUS OBJECTIVES
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO SEE
THE ABUSES AT THE AGENCIES.
THE FBI IS INTER
THE FBI IS INTE
THE FBI IS INTIM
THE FBI IS INTIMAT
THE FBI IS INTIMATEL
THE FBI IS INTIMATELY
THE FBI IS INTIMATELY F
THE FBI IS INTIMATELY FAM
THE FBI IS INTIMATELY FAMIL
THE FBI IS INTIMATELY FAMILIA
THE FBI IS INTIMATELY FAMILIAR
WITH THE PRESENTATIONS AND
THEY'RE WELCOME TO MAKE PUBLIC
TO THE GREATEST EXTENT POSSIBLE
ALL THE INFORMATION THEY HAVE ON
THESE ABUSES.
REGARDLESS, IT'S CLEAR THAT TOP
OFFICIALS USED UNVERIFIED
INFORMATION TO FUEL AN
INTELLIGENCE INFORMATION DURING
A POLITICAL CAMPAIGN.
ONCE THE TRUTH COMES OUT WE CAN
BEGIN TO TAKE STEPS OUR
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES IN COURT
WILL NEVER ABUSE IT AGAIN.
THEY'RE TRYING TO DELEGITIMIZE
THE MEMO BECAUSE THE MEMO,
CLEARLY, ACCORDING TO DEVIN
NUNES EXPOSES TOP OFFICIALS
USING UNVERIFIED CLINTON BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR DOSSIER AS THE
JUSTIFICATION TO SPY ON AN
OPPOSITION CAMPAIGN DURING AN
ELECTION AND THE PRESIDENT-ELECT
AND HIS TEAM.
TO BE CLEAR, THE MEDIA WILL
NEVER REPORT THIS.
FILE MEMBERS WHO WORK EVERY DAY
AT THE FBI, DOJ AND INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY.
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT AND
WE'RE SPECIFIC ARE A FEW BAD
ACTORS IN THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT
ARE ON THE VERGE OF BEING
EXPOSED FOR COMMITTING MASSIVE
CONSTITUTIONAL VIOLATIONS.
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE TRYING TO
KEEP THE MEMO FROM COMING OUT
AND YOU HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY
OF STONEWALLING, DEVIN NUNES AND
THE HOUSE INTEL COMMITTEE, WE
KNOW ROD ROSENSTEIN AND
BEGGING NOT GIVE ACCESS TO THE
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION CONSENT
AND TO SPEAKER RYAN'S CREDIT HE
HELD HIS GROUND IN THE MEETING.
IF THEY DID NOTHING WRONG, THEN
WHY FIGHT SO HARD TO PREVENT
CONGRESS FROM SEEING THE
DOCUMENTS?
RELEASE THE MEMO AND UNDERLYING
DOCUMENTS WITH IT.
THE DOCUMENTATION OF IT ALL.
IF THEY DID NOTHING WRONG WHY
ARE THEY TRYING TO STOP THE MEMO
FROM COMING OUT?
WHY DON'T TOP FBI AND DOJ